you do moune c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
on se trouve sur jouer la dir lentement
pour une fois ok aujourd'hui on est sûr
il était une fois squeeze un jeu fait
par pas teaser games qui est un abonné
un grand merci à lui c'est parti on va
jouer ici à un jeu rageant je retire
tout de suite mon versé il était une
fois squeeze un jeune homme qui
s'aventuraient jour après jour dans le
monde merveilleux du jeu vidéo
malheureusement pour lui certaines de
ses expéditions s'avérait être punitive
il se sentait de plus en plus
impuissants face à la complexité de
l'univers qui l'entourèrent il décida de
mener l enquête dans le but de découvrir
la raison pour laquelle les jeux sont si
maléfique et finit par trouver qu'il
existe une malédiction jetée aux joueurs
par une créature du nom de dieu foetus
tel un véritable héros squeeze s'élança
sur le territoire du monstre assoiffé de
rage tout en sachant pertinemment que
plus il échouera plus son destin sur la
taf était négative moi c'est sûr saint
georges en plus je meurs plus cher à gc
ca pour le bien de la communauté j
arriverai voilà c'était servette premier
noël à travers les saisons qui m'a tuer
fatalities hockey des pics j'ai pas vu
dit elle a régné à l'époque qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent a régné en démo aux
halles nuls à je pense au thé olalalala
le talent quoi j'ai rust et jaune mot
[ __ ] je vous l'aurais pas tuer on va
passer ça en moins de regarder hop hop
l'araignée on s'en bat les steaks et
sébastien diss qui le chat est amer aux
makes beaucoup trop dur clac clac
oh non ça va débloquer le fleuve est ma
vie elle est nul à chier en fait vous
verse à regarder clac clac
ah non le piquetage et à tort lightbox
un arrêt sur image je ne touche pas les
pics a surtout fait pas de piège hors
jeu les flairé là ça sent le piège mais
qu au nom mais il est super dur sauvage
la france au tout dernier moment où
attend là on ne peut pas y aller c'est
impossible c'est pas beau simek ou alors
on prend de la vitesse
oh la la c'est la débandade la samro en
fait faut doser le surveiller on peut
sauter comme ça et comme ça ça c'est bon
ça c'est bon oh non mais 400 chaînes
direct attendons là on a le style qui
arrive on regarde et on passe tous
vraiment de manière aisée bannière easy
ok on passe à l'hiver annoncé depuis
qu'on les voit pas vu qu'il neige à
l'effort et l'effort pack teaser game oh
oui alors la mecque
attention pic j'ai envie de chialer
salle est infernal ça va être infernale
et surtout les arrêtés ont fait les
pièges comme ça qui te tombe sur la
gueule et tu es obligé de me [ __ ]
l'album j'étais pas sur les pics itunes
et de gueuler hockey offre une saison
passée j'avais oublié à temps mais qu'ai
je suis en train de vraiment de perdre
la boule et sa faune la passe mais qui
n'ont fait que je sauve de plus loin
c'est pas parce que du coup maintenant
qu'on est ce qu'il est on va passer tout
ça sans aucun [ __ ] de problème ça
passe
non notre auto ça va le faire ça le
faire c'est lucio n'ai pas peur mon papa
était un peu fou aujourd'hui j'ai des
gens qui lui colle un jeu pour faire
rager au passage points mais elle est
belle on lira tué de dieu foetus j'ai
raté c'est quoi ça
laissez moi j'y allais c'est moi allez
annonce suit dreux d'aller jusqu'au bout
de mes bras salut je suis patrick
araignée j'ai mis des araignées dans les
arbres pour péter les couilles à ce coup
ci ça marche super bien
ok non ça ne fait pas c'est non non
c'était pas écrit comme ça la destinée
cette vidéo au coeur des bourdes et bon
teint teint lier piège
voilà non je suis prêt c'était la
dernière saison on avait la pizza après
la 4 saisons j'arrive plus à rien [ __ ]
j'ai fait que je prenne du recul sur ce
qui va se passer
c'est alors la semaine de l'humour à la
je vais vous dire patrick sébastien que
je fasse un numéro au plus grand cabaret
du monde
j'aime gmt sur le terrain
des gestes bras qui se relance
ben d'ériger mai
non je m'écoute çà et là reconnaît trio
commises amigos et où l'état soy
réfléchisse et à mahfad l'espagnol du
coup je me suis dit qu'est [ __ ] ça
lucas sochard mes goûts stars âgées des
ventes de una royaux vidéo del amo louis
ah oui oui oui oui oh là là là là et la
mecque
c'était quoi le piège là on est bien
l'année vient alors le chef fait pas
chaud derrière ou chaudes devant le
double piège il vient de loin et met son
teint il est ce qui frappe la pipe band
métier paul stopper renier son identité
j'arriverai à passer ce niveau il en va
de mon devoir j'y arriverais pour toute
ma communauté
aymen finalement avec sa phrase dans
leur trou allez cette fois regarder
d'une traite je ne m'arrête pas tarder à
dessous je vous racontais l'histoire
d'alexion debreu alexandre eux c'était
ok cette fois pour de vrai d'une très
dur ou raconter l'histoire de l'eau du
luth de ludovic kiwi ludovic c'était un
jeune gars au collège qui adorait manger
du kiwi et il était très poilu comme les
kiwis du coup on l'appelle et domi kiwi
ok ok ça se trouve le premier trou là
qu'on bosse au [ __ ] j'ai eu peur du
qu'on peut aller là
y a un père sur la fin avec ses obligés
les poils au milieu ou esquiver le trou
et l'araignée lalalala en seulement 45
minutes il avait crevé ok alors que c
est que ça à des fantômes au ça fait
peur
on va pas ou bien des pièges à d'accord
on va aller tout droit voire ya
plusieurs chemins possibles mais qu au
nom auquel va tourner en face et on va
et steve et le monde ce qui se cache
dans la poubelle on esquive à ok vous
devez posséder trois clés pour continuer
mais non pas dans la poubelle on a
trouvé une clé et de sud
on peut pas ouvrir la vieille clé cachée
là bas comme on y va oh non c'est la
douille l'arrière bon c'est sûr peut
passer au dessus un nom pouvait pas y
aller comment faire parler dans la pièce
secrète qui en bas ça je me demande où
j'allais dire j'ai appris à passer au
dessus de ces faut peut-être prendre
l'autre clé avant l'ag de clés ah ok
voilà fallait prendre celle de droite
avant le génie qui postule au génie qui
positionne on dira rien à tanger tng
pacéen ma vie c'est de la merde sinon
hockey ont des bons peuvent leur passé
juste à un fantôme et une poubelle
le fantôme c'est fait la poubelle mec
by the stars de cette vidéo sûr il était
une fois squeeze gts nous a plu ces cas
n'hésitez pas et me dokhan d'habitude on
se fera les 2 prochains niveaux donc le
troisième niveau qui a l'air aussi dur
que le premier et le quatrième qui est
donc le boss de dieu fais tu seras ces
deux là dans une prochaine vidéo écoutez
j'espère qu'on va tous défoncés alors
totale itt pour faire la suite je vais
juste décompresser car et ses deux chats
et aller mieux à la truite dans une
prochaine vidéo partez vous bien de
changement ou pis
en